Speaker 1: at the end of the day, no matter
what Trump says. If he doesn't have followers
in the Republican Party, it doesn't really
matter. But he does have followers. Matt Gaetz,
Marjorie Taylor Greene, Herschel Walker and
others. But if nobody pays attention or takes
them seriously, then it doesn't really matter.
But unfortunately, there are tens of millions
of people who love this. I hesitate to even
call it a movement. It's sort of a perversion
of a movement, but there are tens of millions
of people, and here are a few of them who
went to the Trump rally over the weekend.
Here is a woman who believes things have been
so bad under Joe Biden that obviously everybody
is going to vote Trump in 2024 specifically.
Speaker 4: So, you know, Trump is going to
have a lot to do, a lot of work, but he's
the one that knows how to do it. And the people
there didn't vote for Trump. They're going
to do it this time because they've been taught
a hard lesson. Yeah, well, a hard lesson.
Speaker 1: So that's a very optimistic Trump
supporter saying they learned the hard way,
they learned the hard way. And of course,
what we've learned is Trump's willing to try
to steal an election he lost in order to stay
in power, ignoring all elements of democracy
and checks and balances in this country. Here's
just kind of a funny, cringy moment. There's
a guy in the audience at the rally who wrote
what he describes as a very patriotic song,
but nobody will listen to it. So he insists
on giving us a few lines. This this is this
is weird.
Speaker 4: We're trying to release a patriotic
song. I can't get anyone to listen to it here.
All right, guys want to hear it? Yeah. Oh,
you're going to sing it? No, it's a missionary
friend of mine that wrote it, but I played
it for a few people in Houston and they said,
you were going to get back to
Speaker 1: me, but to people in Houston said,
Let me think about it. That's not that's not
bad. That's a ringing endorsement.
Speaker 4: It starts off life, liberty and
truth worth fighting for. Honor loving. And
truth is worth dying for. And it mentions
everything about the great awakening. But
I can't get anyone to listen to it.
Speaker 1: I can't imagine why. I mean, it's
such he's such an inspiring speaker, and it's
such a such a prescient message
Speaker 4: that sounds like a great song.
It's kind of bad. No one wants to listen to
it. Well, just everybody's busy. You know,
everybody's doing something. Yeah, well, how
do we hear it? If this guy gave me a car and
I've said since,
Speaker 1: I thought I will mail you a cassette
tape with the song on it. Continuing our tour
of the Trump rally, another guy at the Trump
rally had a suggestion for balancing the budget.
So no shortage of economic ideas presented
either Ali here.
Speaker 4: How's it going, sir? You know how
they can, how they can balance the budget?
How's that? Drill two oil wells in Alaska
and let it all go to the national budget.
And then we won't have no worries about inflation,
either to take care of it. I missed the day
Trump back in there to take care of our land.
Biden needed to retire. Highest need to retire.
Pelosi needs to retire Schumer and long mediums
apart.
Speaker 1: It sounds like he's saying retard,
but I guess he's saying retire. Yeah, OK,
so he has some economic ideas which are very,
very interesting. And then lastly, here's
a guy wearing an American flag jacket with
an f j b that's, you know, f Joe Biden hat
on. Who drove, I guess, to Georgia from New
York and waited six hours in line. Now I'm
not ridiculing this. Understand the level
of commitment and devotion that some of these
people have. I mean, I'm the first one to
say. I don't know of anyone who would do that
to just hear Joe Biden speak, not because
they don't support Biden, but because there's
not a cult like obsession with him as an individual.
It's just as he's doing an okay job. As president,
I don't need to drive across the country to
listen to the guy. I'll watch it on TV, but
understand that it's important that they have
this level of commitment.
Speaker 4: What he's doing over there in Poland
right now going to be an ass GS of Ukraine.
He's making a sell. He hasn't been to the
southern border, but he's been over to Ukraine.
Exactly. Yeah, it's awesome. Well, we hope
he shows. It really is. It really is. So you
guys from Georgia?
Speaker 1: OK. Anyway, so then the guy goes
on to say he drove there from New York and
stood in line for six hours and et cetera,
et cetera. We. If we misunderstand these people,
they're going to win again. It's it's just
the reality of the situation. And so it needs
to be taken very seriously and we are now.
It's easy to laugh and say, guys, it's been
almost two years since the election. They're
still saying it was stolen. They still call
on President Trump. They still say he's really
the president, and we laugh and we point.
But that is a level of devotion, a cult like
devotion that fortunately doesn't exist on
the left. Like, you know, I don't really care
about politicians from a personality standpoint.
It's like, Are you? Are you going to do the
things you promised and are you going to do
things I agree with? That's it. I'm not. I'm
not driving anywhere. I'm not. There's no
cult like interest. But this is exactly what
could rocket them back to the Oval Office
as soon as 2024, so it should not be ignored.
A dystopian horror effec weekend in Georgia.